and so guys my name is Ana and welcome
back to my say boss boss series so today
I'm gonna be talking a little bit more
about memory and specifically how we can
track allocation and the allocation of
memory now the thing about memory is
that it's important I'm gonna keep
talking about memory probably forever
because that's how computers work
computers are very very closely tied in
with memory if you just have a CPU and
you don't have any RAM you don't have
any memory then nothing really is going
to happen and because it's such a
popular topic for discussion a lot of
people sometimes have the wrong idea
about memory and I think this is further
complicated by the fact that it's 2020
we don't really have that big of an
issue with memory like we did 20 years
ago
we have gigabytes and gigabytes of
memory I have like 32 gigabytes in my
computer most laptops come with like 8
or 16 gigabytes of memory it's kind of
difficult to write a C++ program that's
gonna use that amount or more I mean not
that difficult and definitely depends on
what you're doing but it's still hello
world is not gonna use too much memory
so anyway my point with all of this is
that sometimes it's useful to know when
your program allocates memory
specifically on the heap of course is
what we're talking about if you know
where your program allocates memory you
can potentially work to reduce it
therefore potentially optimizing your
program and making it run faster because
allocating memory on the heap is is not
the best thing to do especially in
performance critical code on top of that
being able to see where memory is being
allocated can also help you discover a
little bit more about how your program
works even if you wrote all of the code
that you're currently running and we
just like forget about this if I lost on
a library LSU saves all of your code
looking over a life project that you may
have been working on for a while and
being able to see okay you know my
program allocates memory here I forgot
about that well that was something that
was from a long time ago that's useful
information
and we're going to talk about how we can
see exactly where each allocation comes
from as well as track the overall usage
of memory inside our application by just
writing the code to do that not relying
on any other tools whatsoever
and I also want to thank Skillshare for
sponsoring this video for those of you
who don't know what skill Shey is Scotia
is an online learning community for
creatives where millions come together
to take the next step in their creative
journey Skillshare offers thousands of
inspiring classes for creative and
curious people on topics including
illustration design photography video
freelancing and more they've got tons of
stuff on their platform to help you
learn a new skill and one of my favorite
features about skill share is that their
videos are quite concise which means
that I can fit them into my schedule and
I have time to actually use them to
learn something new
a lot of their illustration classes I
particularly like because I'm always
interested in improving my art and they
also have plenty of classes to get you
started on how to make videos make
twenty twenty a year in which you
explore new skills deepen existing
passions and get lost in creativity with
school fairs online classes and with an
annual subscription of less than $10 a
month Skillshare is a great way to do
all of that and the best part is the
skill share is offering the first 500
people who sign up using the link in the
description below to three months of
skill share premium so go ahead and do
that as soon as possible and thank you
as always to Skillshare for sponsoring
this video I also want to thank all of
you for subscribing and watching my
videos because we've hit 200 thousand
subscribers on the channel which is
quite a cool milestone what I thought I
would do for that is do a bit of a QA
I have not done a Q&A video in like five
years
probably so if you guys have questions
for me then drop them in the comment
section below I'll be looking at the
comments of this video to see what I
should include in the Q&A please don't
ask me to fix your card now let's dive
into some card and take a look at how
exactly you can be more aware of where
you're allocating memory so here we have
a completely blank C++ program I'm gonna
use this as the foundation for showing
you guys all of this stuff keep in mind
though that in general everything I'm
going to show you here today you can
easily plug into an existing application
of yours that's kind of the way that I
am intending for it to happen maybe in
the future we'll take a look at this
inside a real project but for now I'm
just gonna strip back all of that kind
of craft all of that extra stuff that
isn't really relevant at all and we're
gonna take a look at the core basics the
first thing I'm gonna do here is write a
little object because this is probably
going to be a good example of a
real-world use case I might have an
object let's just say it contains an X Y
Z we have three integers in here now if
I create it on the stack I'll probably
end up with something like this
however if I create this on the heap by
calling a new object then of course that
will result in a heap allocation and the
point of this video today is how can we
detect things like this the way we're
gonna do that is by overriding the new
operator and specifically we're
overriding this operator globally so to
do that we'll type in void pointer
operator nude and then size t sighs so
what this is is the new operator this
new keyword here is actually a function
that gets called with a particular size
and potentially other arguments as well
by writing this code here we're saying
do not use the operator new that is in
the standard library use this one
instead the linker will actually link in
this function instead now of course it's
good to actually allocate memory here
because that's the point of this your
program probably won't work if you don't
of course you could retrieve the memory
from anywhere the point of this function
is to return a void pointer which is
just a memory address so because we
don't really want to affect the behavior
of our program we'll simply type in
return malloc size so what does it'll do
is allocate the appropriate amount of
memory for us and return a pointer to
that memory so with this change being
the only change that I've made if we run
this normally nothing will change but
this new keyword will now run through
this function which is quite nice
because I could easily type in something
like allocating size bytes for example
and now it will actually print that to
the console and perhaps the other
benefit to simply writing something like
this is that I can now easily stick a
breakpoint here and if I run this
program you'll see that my program
breaks on this line and I
and look at the call stack and I can see
that okay it's coming from this line of
code now of course in this case that's
super obvious but what if we made
something like a string so I should say
we have a string culture now now this is
a small string so it weren't allocate
memory on the heap to store these
characters however we are in debug mode
so it still will outcast in memory if we
launch this now you can see that this
allocation is coming from this line of
code and we can actually track that all
the way in the coalsack through string
and say that okay we call operator new
here and we allocate eight bytes of
memory which is also you can see what
our console reflects just in case it's
not 100% clear I also want to point out
that this does not just affect you
explicitly calling you if you use smart
pointers so for example if this was a
unique pointer and then let's change
this to make you me with object
addressing clear memory up here then
obviously memory will still get
allocated here if I run this code will
skip past the string here to the next
allocation and you can see that this
happens from within make unique because
unique actually of course creates the
object on the heap by calling new so
hopefully you can already see how useful
this is you can stick a breakpoint
inside that operator new function and
trace back exactly where those memory
allocations are coming from another
really good example where this is super
useful is if you're working on a game
engine or a game when the games actually
running when you're rendering frames
like let's just say you finished loading
you finished initialization all of that
you're in your level you're just playing
your game frame to frame you want to
minimize the number of allocations you
have because they that can have a quite
significant performance impact so what
you can do and what I have done in the
past is you can just stick a breakpoint
inside that operating new function while
your game loop is actually running and
kind of trace exactly where those memory
allocations are coming from frame to
frame and to be honest a lot of them I'm
probably gonna be like string operations
and stuff like that but sometimes you
can you can make smarter decisions for
example maybe you have a vector
that keeps getting all resized maybe you
can define that size ahead of time or
use something that doesn't quite
allocate as much memory or maybe you can
write a memory arena or something like
that for a given system or operation or
something in your game loop so that you
can reduce actual memory allocations
that keep hitting the heap it's all
seriously useful stuff if we go back to
this little example of ours we can also
write the matching delete operator which
just looks like this we have operator
delete and then a pointer to the memory
that we want to delete and what we can
do here is just type in free memory and
that's really all there is to it now if
we put a breakpoint here and we maybe
take this unique pointer and put it into
a little scope here what you should see
is this operator delete being called
from this main function after this
unique pointer is destroyed and you can
see that is the actual destructor of
this unique pointer here that is
actually deleting our underlying raw
pointer now if we go back here you'll
learn is that this of course doesn't
actually contain information about the
size so we can't really print anything
like this well I mean we can we just
have to add that parameter in because at
the core this delete operator doesn't
really need size information but you can
optionally obtain that information by
just overriding this specific function
signature so now if we take a look at
this and we just let our program run
naturally making sure that I actually
write something like freeing you can see
that now we allocate 12 bytes we free 12
bytes we allocate another 8 bytes and we
free 8 bytes so now using these two
functions we can create some sort of
allocation tracker we can maintain
allocation metrics we can find out
exactly how much memory is being used
how much is being allocated how much is
being freed all of that stuff which of
course becomes really useful so what
I'll do is I'll come up here and I'll
write a struct called allocation metrics
this will contain a UN 32t which will be
our total allocated memory as well as
our total freed memory
I'll also write a little function here
that tells us our current usage and this
will just be turtle allocated - turtle 3
I'll create a little static
instance of this struct here and then
instead of printing this whole
allocation thing I'll just say s
allocation metrics turtle allocated plus
equal size inside out operating you and
then I'll do the same thing for the
delete operator but of course that'll be
our turtle breed so now what I can do is
maybe write a function called print
usage culture and memory usage so small
clear and this will simply output our
memory usage which will be s allocation
metrics current usage bytes ok cool so
now I can print my memory usage at the
start I can print it off to allocating
this object I might move this string up
to make it a little bit more interesting
and I'll just I'll just put these
everywhere let's just run this program
so now you can see that at the beginning
we're not using any memory then we've
allocated 8 bytes for this actual string
then we've allocated another 12 bytes
for these three integers because we have
three integers three times four is
twelve and then finally we're back down
to eight bytes after the scope ends
because we've freed our unique pointer
pretty cool stuff anyway if you guys
found this helpful go ahead and throw
this into your own programs and actually
test it out and see it in action
I do want to make a note that of course
you could use tools for this you don't
have to write code that does this
yourself you could use visual studios
built-in kind of memory allocation
tracking profiling tools whatever
they're called
valgrind also has some nice tools for
tracking memory and seeing where it's
coming from like allocations coming from
all of that kind of stuff so there are
tools available out there and I might
make some videos on them in the future
but for me personally this is a very
quick and dirty way to actually see what
is actually going on and also trace it
back within your code without having to
kind of use other tools they are
definitely useful and I'm not saying
that you shouldn't use them all I'm
saying is that sometimes it's just a lot
easier and more simple to just write
something like this and instantly be
able to see exactly where those
allocations are coming from and this is
definitely something that I use in my
own technology all the time and in fact
in a bigger kind of game engine for
you would probably have your own kind of
opera new operator to lead all that
stuff because aside from having to just
track metrics and make sure that that
works across all platforms you also may
want to control exactly where that
memory is coming from anyway hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please hit that like button don't forget
to leave any questions that you may have
for me in the comment section below for
that 200k special Q&A video and I will
see you next time goodbye
[Music]